welcome back to our SED Israel's
Ambassador UK has emphatically rejected
any Prospect of a two-state solution
here's what she told Sky News is Mark
Austin is there still a chance for a
two-state solution I think it's about
time for the world to realize the Oslo
Paradigm failed on the 7th of October
and we need to build a new one and in
order to build a new one does that new
one include the Palestinians living in a
state of their own is that what I think
the biggest question is what type of
Palestinians are in the other side this
what Israel
realiz the answer is absolutely no well
her comments followed a start Warning by
President Biden that Israel's
indiscriminate bombing as he put it in
Gaza is weakening international support
and the Prime Minister netanyahu's
right-wing government is making the
prospect of Peace increasingly
impossible joining me now is Mark reg
senior revisor to the Israeli Prime
Minister Mr Reg thank you very much
indeed for joining us again just start
first of all if we could with um
Israel's ambassador of the UK Toby
hotelli out very strongly in this
interview with sky in which she said
there's there's no Prospect of any
two-state solution and that's gone
around the world um do you agree with
that I mean is that it that's that's
done is that Israel's position now well
we're obviously not close to peace at
the moment we're fighting a war against
Kamas and uh we're focused on winning
that war but in a longterm arrangement
we have a formula that is uh simple and
it works I believe and that formula is
is as follows the Palestinians should
have all the rights all the capabilities
to govern themselves and they shouldn't
have the powers that can hurt or
threaten Israel I think that's a
sensible formula so they shouldn't have
their own
State well it depends how you define the
term State I'll give you a should they
have the same rights as Israel for
example well I'll ask you the following
question peers should the Palestinians
if they have State should they be able
to sign let's say a military agreement
military treaty with Iran should they be
able to have an army an Air Force should
they have all those military powers that
could theoretically threaten the state
of Israel and the answer in our view is
clearly no why should they be
prohibited my my question would be why
should they be prohibited from having
exactly the same rights as a state to
Israel wouldn't that be ultimately the
way you actually achieve peace not
allowing the Palestinians to have the
same rights as Israelis has just not
worked has it I mean demonstrably not
work on the contrary if this is going to
work it has to be based on realism we
can't base peace on assumptions that
just aren't based founded on reality and
Yak Rin the prime minister of Israel who
wanted to make peace with the
Palestinians who was the Prime Minister
at the time of the signing of the Oslo
Accords he gave a speech and he was very
clear he said that the Palestinians will
have less than a state Yin said the man
who was shot for his efforts to move
forward on the peace process he said
that the future Palestinian areas will
have to be demilitarized he said that
Jordan Valley that area on the Eastern
edge of the Palestinian territories
would have to remain under Israeli
control the idea that a Palestinian area
will have to be demilitarized in any
future uh settlement that's common
sense and it's been reported and the
Ambassador said yesterday the same
figure that uh the Israeli Defense
Forces has so far killed 7,000 Hamas
terrorists uh do you agree is that the
figure that you think is correct and if
so again I think I've asked you this
before how do you
know well this is what our our
intelligence is telling us this is more
or less the figure we've been hitting
Kamas and we've been hitting their
military machine very uh hard
and we will continue to do so until
we've dismantled their military machine
and taken out their top command
structure how many civilians have you
killed well once again that number is
we're relying here on on Hamas numbers
we don't want to see a single civilian
kill do you know that Piers what does
your intelligence tell you if it's so
sure about the number of Hamas that have
been killed how many civilians have been
killed you must have the same
intelligence
surely I I I agree but I told you I
wasn't sure of the first number either
we're working on approximations what I
can tell you as a matter of policy is we
want to keep the number of Civilian
casualties to the bare minimum but we
Face an enemy that deliberately wants to
see those numbers rise because they see
that as a way to pressure the world to
pressure Israel for a ceasefire because
that's the lifeline for Hamas we are
destroying Hamas peers in the north
we're seeing more and more pamas
terrorists surrender you've seen
pictures today from a particular hospit
hospital where we saw 70 Hamas Fighters
come out with their weapons above their
heads and surrender to the IDF what we
also if I may if I may just pick you up
on that we're also seeing the president
of the United States your biggest Ally
coming out and saying that Israel is
using indiscriminate bombing now that is
a breach of international law he's
basically accusing you of committing war
crimes so we are not carpet bombing the
Gaza Strip we are not indiscriminately
targeting a a why does America's
president think you are well I think the
people who are familiar with the
information know that we have a rigorous
process of Target you he's not getting
good enough
intelligence I I I don't know because
his remarks weren't recorded they were
just reported and I don't know exactly
how he said it or in what context but I
do know well he used the phrase
indiscriminate bombing and as you know
that is a war crime if that is the case
that is that that is not correct that is
not correct Israel does not
indiscriminately bomb Gaza you can
actually see the pictures you see a
house that is standing next to a house
that has been destroyed when there's a
Hamas Target we go after that Target we
do not I repeat do not indiscriminately
bombing Gaza CNN has reported today that
40 to
55% of the 29,000 air to ground
Munitions uh used by Israel have been
unguided dumb bombs uh which have a lack
of precision and therefore expose a much
higher threat to civilians in dense
populated areas is that figure
correct no first of all I would reject
the the the the use of the term Dum
bombs there are different types of
Munitions but and we don't Target a a a
facility we don't Target a site unless
there is clear intelligence that there
is a Hamas Target that needs to be taken
out I want to stress that again and
again and again we have rules of stages
that must be uh must be met before we
target before we use Munitions there
there's a process of identification of
intelligence analysis of then a
discussion what is the correct Munitions
for that particular Target and only then
will we act to destroy the
target uh new British foreign secretary
David Cameron former prime minister of
course has come out today and said that
extremist settlers by targeting and
killing Palestinian civilians it means
on the West Bank are undermining
security and stability for both Israelis
and Palestinians Israel must take
stronger action to stop settle of
violence and hold the perpetrators
accountable we are Banning this is the
UK those responsible for settle of
violence from entering the UK to make
sure our country cannot be a home for
people who commit these intimidating
acts strong words to Mr Cameron your
response well we we we're as a
government we're opposed to any sort of
vigilante violence and we will arrest
people who are involved in it from our
point of view anyone who who acts that
way is acting against the law and we'll
bring the justice system down against
them we'll make arrests and people will
go to jail but I think it must be said
that if one looks on the violence in the
West Bank and of course we condemn and
we act against vigilante Jewish violence
but the overwhelming majority of the
violence 99% of it is in the other
direction and that has to be it has to
be put in perspective your intelligence
tell you do your intelligence figures
what do they tell you in terms of number
of is Israelis killed on the West Bank
by Palestinians since October the 7th
and conver the number of number of
Palestinians killed by Israelis
so first of all we had that terrible
attack in Jerusalem just last week which
you recall I just wonder whether you
know what the the relative figures are
no no we've taken out many more Kamas
terrorists because what we've tried to
do over the last few weeks since this
crisis Hamas didn't operate on the West
Bank I've been repeatedly assured PE of
course it does peers of course they
operate on the West Bank they're not the
government on the West Bank the where
they are in Gaza so what are the
numbs you have commas cells across the
West Bank right but what are the numbers
how many Palestinians have died on the
West Bank since the start of this and
how many Israelis I can't give you a
figure I I didn't bring that to the
interview and I apologize maybe you have
a figure for me I just know that it's
it's I don't have the precise numbers
but I know it's massively higher number
of palestin it is but that but once
again we're not talking about civilians
we're not talking about uninvolved
people we of civilians Hamas terrorists
and disagree honly we are being as
surgical listen as you know I've always
said is has a right to defend itself
after what happened I stand by that the
proportionality of that response I think
is becoming increasingly concerning to
everybody including the American
president um but I think on the West
Bank it is inarguable that the behavior
of these settlers the extremist settlers
is completely out of control now and
surely you would see that that is aside
from everything else that is the least
justifiable part of all of this isn't it
but I'm not justifying it neither is the
government of Israel where if people are
acting in a vigilante way the state will
act against them they'll be arrested and
they'll go through the courts and if
they've committed crimes they'll go to
jail there's no excuse for it no one's
justifying it all I'm saying to you is
the government of Israel acts firmly
against extremist violence but to be
fair I can ask you does the Palestinian
Authority on the West Bank do they act
against their extremist violence and the
answer is no do you know we're talking
where where what is it we're close to 70
days since the October 7th Massacre and
the Palestinian Authority the so-called
moderates have yet to condemn that
terrible atrocious attack against
civilians that's the difference we
condemn extremism we fight extremism
what do they do last time you came on I
asked you whether we could have an
interview with prime minister Netanyahu
he's not given one yet to any European
television network as far as I'm aware
outside of Israel and uh and he's also
talked to American networks I ask you
again will he come and talk to us
I I have to tell you he hasn't done an
interview at all since we spoke last so
don't feel discriminated against peers
he hasn't done a single interview uh
when he starts doing other interviews
again your name will come up thank you
Mr rer thank you very much indeed
appreciate it my pleasure
sir